Speaker 1: radical right wing media outlet
and is attempting to resurface from the bottom
of the trash heap.
And they are doing so with a so-called exclusive
interview with Donald Trump, which is really
indistinguishable from North Korean propaganda.
All of the same tired lies were resuscitated.
The really wacky intangible here is the performance
of the interviewer, whose name is Chanel Reon.
We really can't tell this apart from one of
those North Korea propaganda interviews.
Now, first, check out just the introduction
to the interview and the first line of the
interview.
It's desperately sycophantic.
This doesn't even count as journalism even
in the U.S.
And our journalism standards are really low,
really, really low.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 7: President Donald J. Trump left
an indelible mark on U.S. politics from the
25th floor of his iconic New York headquarters.
One America News sat down with our forty fifth
president for an exclusive one on one discussion
there.
He shared with us his forecast, his fears
and his hopes for America's horizon.
In the process, we witness an illuminating
snapshot into the mind of a man whose leadership
and battles sparked a movement that forever
altered the course of American history.
This is an open, exclusive interview from
New York City, New York.
Mr. President, we sit here in Trump Tower
many days and many miles from what many Americans
consider an illegitimate Biden White House.
Speaker 1: In the first line of the introduction,
she has to mention Biden is an illegitimate
president, as many people see it.
Mr. President, when you crowbar illegitimate
Biden into the opener, you know, it's going
to be utterly insane.
And it got way wackier when Trump started
talking.
Here is Donald Trump ranting about a so-called
Third World election in the United States.
And Shantel Ryan, just a Shanelle Ryan, just
can't help but can't help but try pushing
that same thing about O fraud.
Any day now, we're going to uncover the fraud.
Speaker 5: And if we can convince people that
that won't happen again or if we don't get
right down to the bottom of it and change
it, that those people aren't going to be there
to vote Republican.
The Republicans are going to have to do something,
whether it's Mitch McConnell or Kevin McCarthy,
for the leadership locally, they have to do
something.
There was a an expression that I've heard
that you've heard for many years.
The vote counter is far more important than
the politician or the person running for office.
And that was the case in this instance for
the presidential election.
Very sad that this could happen.
It was a third world election.
Speaker 7: Well, it looks like a lot of that
may well be uncovered very shortly.
Speaker 5: Spring uncovered and we see that.
And it'd be nice if the papers would report
it.
Speaker 1: There is so much going on here.
First of all, on the technical level, why
is the audio always terrible with these on
interviews, the amount of room noise, background
noise, Artec is a disaster.
We never have a background noise issue like
that.
Like, I have no idea what I'm doing, but my
interviews never sound like that.
How can only end in an interview with the
president not make it sound reasonable?
What I'm realizing is that an interview with
a real anchor or journalist and Trump, it's
already wacky just because of the things that
Donald Trump says.
But at least when there is a sort of real
interviewer, the questions can sometimes get
back on track.
There can sometimes be an attempt to hold
Donald Trump accountable for what he's saying.
What channel Ryan from on is doing is participating
in the shared delusions with Donald Trump.
Trump says crazy stuff about fraud.
And instead of asking for receipts, she asks
she adds to it by saying, oh, yeah, any day
now we're going to uncover the fraud.
Here's another piece of this in which Donald
Trump, again, claims to have blockbuster technology
coming.
This is great because for months he touted
a new digital communication social media platform
that he was going to be launching.
And instead he just launched a blog.
It's just like Blogspot Technology installed
on his website.
And now, again, he's teasing.
He has something really big coming.
Speaker 5: So we had a couple of hundred million
people.
And the problem is a lot of these platforms,
you can't put that many people on.
It just doesn't work.
If they explode, if you put.
Five hundred thousand on, it's like a lot
and they can't handle it and the technology
just isn't there right now for that, but the
technology is coming very rapidly and we're
working on something that I think will be
a blockbuster when it happens.
It's going to be something that's going to
be special.
But, you know, I've been offered companies
for almost nothing, big chunks of companies
that have platforms.
The problem is they can't.
All the people.
Speaker 1: Yeah, the platforms out there just
can't handle the amount of people that want
to follow Trump.
What?
Facebook can't hold Trump's audience.
Twitter can't hold Trump's audience.
YouTube can't hold it.
These are delusions of the highest level.
And Shanelle Ryan is just helping him along.
And then we get to the point of the interview
where Trump again claims the election results
aren't possible.
He just doesn't believe that he lost.
So obviously, it must be fraud.
Speaker 5: What people want to talk about
is it all comes down to what happened in the
election because you look at Georgia.
Georgia is fantastic.
What happened to all those votes?
What happened to all those people that was
standing on the line wearing red hats and
wearing all sorts of things that what happened?
And then you look at Michigan and you look
at how do you win Ohio and a record in Florida
in our record and South Carolina and a record
in Iowa and a record.
And then you lose Michigan and you lose Pennsylvania.
We were up at 10, 30 in the evening by so
much in Pennsylvania, it wasn't doable unless
something crooked
Speaker 1: happened to
the popular vote in twenty sixteen.
He will never admit that he lost in 2020.
And it's the same talking points now.
Six months out from the election, we were
leading at 10 p.m. and suddenly there were
these massive dumps of ballots and then we
were losing.
It's over and over and over again.
The same talking point.
Let's look at just one more clip and then
we'll move on.
Trump asked about Joe Biden on China.
What was Biden's first mistake?
Here we go.
See if you can understand this.
Speaker 7: China, what was Biden's first mistake?
Speaker 5: Well, I think he made many mistakes.
Number one, he's shown such weakness.
You know, they have planes flying over Taiwan
now.
They never had this.
You know, they never had these weapons.
You wouldn't have had this problem in Israel.
They didn't shoot rockets when I was they
were still shooting thousands of rockets into
Israel.
That wouldn't have happened with me.
Speaker 7: Well, within four years, your administration
brokered historic peace deals in the Middle
East.
And within four months, the Biden administration
essentially is overseeing a war,
Speaker 1: just total fantasy world views
of how things work.
Biden showed weakness, but then he says something
about Israel.
Instead, the question was about China.
Now, I do think there are people who see interviews
like this and they do think Trump has an idea
what he's talking about.
That's the really scary part.
And we know that that's the case because.
Seventy four million people voted for the
guy.
But it's really something else.
How vapid and meaningless what he says is.
And having a reporter help him along, as Shanelle
Ryan did in this, it's very dark for what
it portends about journalism in the United
States.
If you can even really still call this journalism,
and I don't think you can let me know what
you think.
Very depressing and bizarre interview